Traduttore: Ana Birsa
Revisore: Marco Caresia
(Applausi)
Sono nato il 1 settembre del 1971.
Qui.
La faccio vedere
per scatenare un po' d'invidia.
Non è un caso che io sia nato lì,
perché appartengo ad una famiglia
che ha fatto del viaggiare
il proprio marchio di fabbrica.
Mio nonno dal '37 al '47
era in Africa orientale.
Nello stesso momento,
suo fratello gemello stava in Argentina.
Mio padre andò, dopo la guerra,
in Argentina, dove conobbe mia madre,
che era nata vicino a qui.
Ho 45 anni e sono molto curioso.
Conosco un sacco di cose
per averle sentite, ascoltate, lette.
Ma una cosa la so da me:
viaggiare fuori ti cambia dentro.
Il mio primo volo l'ho fatto
che avevo 9 mesi di vita.
Non ho nessun ricordo di quel volo,
però qualcosa deve essere successo
se poi, in seguito, avrei fatto 250 voli
di cui almeno 34 intercontinentali.
I primi 12 anni della mia vita
li ho passati tra i due continenti.
Tra l'America e l'Europa,
tra l'Italia e l'Argentina.
Ogni quattro anni, mediamente,
cambiavamo Paese e continente.
In tutto questo viaggiare,
in questo peregrinare
la mia compagna di viaggio
era mia sorella gemella,
con la quale ho condiviso
la scuola e il tempo libero.
Quando volevo che gli altri
non capissero cosa volevo dire
le parlavo nel nostro codice segreto
che era: l'italiano,
quando eravamo in Argentina;
lo spagnolo, quando eravamo in Italia.
Ecco, questa è una cosa
che io ho: sono bilingue.
Lo sono a livello di poter sostenere
una conversazione con mio figlio,
parlando io in spagnolo,
e lui rispondendomi in italiano.
Chi di voi parla lingue straniere
sa che questa cosa
non è per niente semplice.
Io l'ho scoperto con mia madre.
Mia madre è madrelingua spagnola,
ha imparato l'italiano
quand'era già adulta.
Io le ho chiesto, chiaramente,
di parlare con i miei figli in spagnolo.
Ma lei non ce la fa.
Quando mio figlio le risponde in italiano,
lei attacca a parlare in italiano.
E [come] potete immaginare,
mi sono innervosito
più di una volta su questa situazione.
Lei mi dice: 'È che faccio confusione'.
Bene, è proprio la confusione,
la questione vera e importante.
C'è un'interessante ricerca
della Anglia Ruskin University,
dove hanno fatto un confronto
tra bambini bilingue e bambini monolingue.
E hanno scoperto che i bambini bilingue
sono molto più capaci dei monolingue
di mantenere focalizzata l'attenzione.
Si sono chiesti come mai,
e la risposta è questa:
di fatto,
ogni volta che un bambino bilingue
deve affrontare la realtà
ha sempre almeno
due etichette, due parole,
che possono essere utilizzate.
E ogni volta deve tenerne una
e sopprimerne un'altra.
Tenerne una e sopprimerne un'altra.
Questa operazione allena, a lungo andare,
la capacità di rimanere focalizzato,
rispetto a quello che è
il lavoro che si deve fare.
È solo questo il vantaggio?
No, ce ne sono anche altri.
Per esempio, l'Università di Ghent
ha scoperto che nelle persone bilingue
i sintomi dell'Alzheimer
compaiono cinque anni dopo,
in media, rispetto ai monolingue.
E altre ricerche dicono che i bilingue
hanno una capacità creativa
maggiore dei monolingue.
Questo perché?
Perché, tendenzialmente, le lingue
ci aiutano a descrivere la realtà.
E lo fanno con sfumature che sono diverse.
Queste sfumature non coincidono mai.
Sono sfumature che ci permettono
di descrivere in altro modo la realtà.
E allora, quando io ne ho due,
queste sfumature creano una situazione
che mi obbliga ad avere
una profondità maggiore
nella conoscenza della realtà.
È un po' come con la vista.
Se io guardo con un solo occhio,
un'immagine è piatta.
Se io, invece, guardo con tutti
e due gli occhi, ho la profondità.
Questo perché?
Perché ho due immagini
che non sono uguali,
hanno delle sfasature.
Ma il nostro cervello
poi le ricompone,
e ci dà la profondità.
Con le culture succede la stessa cosa.
Succede che, in qualche modo,
il dover comporre regole,
comportamenti, modi di vita diversi
ci obbliga ad avere una profondità
maggiore di comprensione.
Vi faccio un piccolo esempio.
Nel 1983 ero appena
tornato dall'Argentina,
dove avevo comprato una tuta in felpa.
Era una tuta che mi piaceva molto.
Erano le prime che giravano,
ne andavo molto orgoglioso.
E ricordo di aver deciso
di andare a scuola
vestito con questa tuta.
Sono andato a scuola, sono entrato,
mi sono seduto
e Matteo, il mio compagno,
mi guarda e mi dice:
"Belletti, ma che fai?
Oggi non c'è mica ginnastica!"
Allora lì ho capito subito,
perché mi sono guardato attorno
e ho visto che, effettivamente,
ero l'unico che aveva su la tuta.
Ho capito che in Italia
l'abito fa il monaco.
E che c'è un dress code
per qualsiasi cosa.
Che tutti conoscono, ma non è scritto.
Mentre in Argentina uno può
andare vestito così come vuole.
Allora, mi sono dovuto interrogare
su che cosa stava succedendo.
E nel trovare una risposta,
ho acquisito una maggiore
profondità di conoscenza,
rispetto, ad esempio, a come ci si veste.
E come il vestire non sia
una cosa data per assodata,
ma dipenda dalle culture.
C'è solo questo?
No, ci sono anche altre cose.
Per esempio, il World Economic Forum
ha stilato una classifica
delle 10 skill più rilevanti per il 2020.
Ora, almeno cinque di queste
possono essere tranquillamente
allenate e sviluppate
nel momento in cui io
abito in un Paese diverso.
Mi concentro solo sul primo,
Il complex problem solving.
Che è fondamentale:
è la capacità di risolvere
problemi e situazioni complesse.
Immaginate che allenamento continuo
e quotidiano ha una persona straniera
che si trova a dover capire
se le cose che sta facendo
sono corrette oppure no
per la cultura nella quale si trova.
È un allenamento continuo,
dal momento in cui mi alzo la mattina
al momento in cui vado a dormire.
Insomma, quello che vi voglio dire è:
andate ad abitare all'estero!
Viaggiate, fate questa esperienza.
Tra l'altro, se avete meno di 29 anni,
e qualcuno qua in sala è sicuramente così,
avete un'opportunità incredibile.
Oggi ci sono mille modi
per poterlo fare a basso costo.
Io vi do solo due parole,
poi andate a cercarle:
Erasmus Plus e Servizio
Volontario Europeo.
Sono due splendide opportunità
per poter viaggiare,
abitare in altri Paesi,
e sviluppare tutte queste competenze
praticamente pagando nulla.
Se poi non volete andare da nessuna parte,
perché dite: "Ho il mutuo,
ho tante cose, non ce la posso fare".
Benissimo, questo non è un problema,
perché abbiamo il mondo dietro casa.
In una città come Torino,
basta andare un po' in periferia
e lì troviamo il mondo.
Troviamo una marea di gente
che si trova nella condizione
che ho descritto prima io con la tuta.
Gente che si fa continuamente
delle domande su come noi viviamo.
E che cerca delle risposte.
Se noi fossimo in grado di cogliere
quelle domande, quegli interrogativi,
ci permetterebbe di avere una comprensione
più profonda della nostra realtà.
E magari cambiarla, anche.
Del resto, l'innovazione
è questa roba qui, no?
L'innovazione è la possibilità
di mettere insieme dei diversi.
Ma ci vuole una narrazione nuova,
una narrazione che sia più favorevole.
Pensate, quest'uomo,
Carlos Pellegrini, italo-argentino.
diventa Presidente della Repubblica
Argentina a fine '800.
Questo avviene a vent'anni esatti
dalla prima massiccia immigrazione
italiana in quel Paese.
È come se oggi,
a vent'anni dalla prima massiccia
immigrazione albanese in Italia,
avessimo un Presidente
del Consiglio italo-albanese.
Possibile?
Grazie.
(Applausi)